top media outlets forced to retract a
major claim about rudy giuliani after
the dramatic raid on his apartment but
only after
it was repeated nbc news has confirmed
that the fbi warned giuliani as well as
senator ron johnson a republican senator
back in 2019 that the two of them were
the target of a russian
influence campaign the washington post
reports that the fbi
personally warned giuliani in 2019 that
he was the target of a russian influence
operation
new york times washington post and nbc
news now issuing retractions after
claiming that the fbi warned rudy
giuliani
he was the target of a russian
disinformation campaign
and the former mayor is defending to see
is demanding to see rather
their anonymous sources
okay okay dana sorry about that
dana you know this anonymous source
issue is one that
the media has been dealing with for a
very long time and retractions are great
except for they never get as much
attention as
the original story with the incorrect
information
so i don't know who their sources are
but i have a feeling
it's the same sources but it's the same
source for all of them
but then it's the same sources from the
last three times that this has happened
um and at some point you might want to
push back
on these sources and not take their
calls anymore i mean i would i'd be so
mad if that this happened to me i would
never speak to them again
greg yeah i um how many stories
do we need to see happen before we
realize
that this is the this is crazy you go
back to
i mean this isn't a silly story about a
hamburger like you know
on the five we'll talk about something
and it turns out that it's just
something silly and stupid
and we laugh about it but all of these
stories um
exist because they have a punitive
consequence
that overrides the need to fact check
like if if
if the story was about you know joe
biden somebody might go the extra mile
but if it's on the other side or if they
think that you're evil or immoral
you will not get that kind of treatment
we saw this with russian collusion which
was basically just a landscape
of similar errors and the next day day
after that there
always turned out to be false you could
almost set your watch to it you have the
fine people hoax you have the drinky
bleach hoax you have smilet
covington swetnick you have the endless
parade of hate crime hoaxes
everyone initially gets these stories
wrong because they want to be first
there's a punitive element to it
which is the intention to hurt somebody
and then it falls apart and like
everything else reject retraction's just
gonna get
lost in the ether as we all move on to
the next story
yeah one doesn't this confirmation bias
run amok as well
they get one anonymous source they
confirm it they assume it's true
turns out to be false a lot of the time
well i think if you're at a big time
paper like the new york times washington
post nbc news i mean
there are consequences remember they
fired a bunch of cnn people who got
something wrong about donald trump
so i'm glad to see them clean it up i
think any time these outlets
don't clean it up and don't clean it up
quickly they sacrificed their own
credibility katie
uh but in this case let me just say the
bottom line for me
rudy giuliani is still in a world of
trouble they don't preser they don't
prepare those kinds of briefings about
russian uh you know attempts to control
you
unless something's going on and senator
johnson said he was brief he said he
didn't
really learn anything from it uh the
fact that they didn't brief rudy doesn't
mean
that that raid that went on the other
day isn't a signal they're about to
indict him
and when it comes to cleaning up things
i wish conservatives if this is just
political
would be quick about cleaning up the big
lie from trump about a stolen election
and all those republicans who didn't
vote to certify joe biden's election
a possible it's impossible too right
that is an opinion
we're talking about the actual facts
yeah yeah just
i know but that what i'm saying is
people can disagree and you're not gonna
you can sit there and have an opinion a
conversation about it we're talking here
about actual facts that were
shown to be false
you're missing my point if one yeah if
one if one really believes that rudy
giuliani as they say was the victim of a
russia disinformation campaign
then why didn't he get briefed juan
don't you think you should tell an
american hero like rudy
that the russians are trying to
influence you
do the same thing they did with trump
right
they actually don't brief the trump
campaign
and then they entrap trump and said
that's the game juan
there's no russia disinformation against
rudy there's american media
disinformation against rudy
the same intel sources leak the same
lies
to the same mainstream reporters the
same bylines
every time same managing editors have to
sign off on it
they actually have a code of ethics for
anonymous sourcing
and dana nailed one of them the
anonymous source has to be credible
but if the same anonymous source is
leaking the same fake news for four
years
he's not credible anymore so why are
they running it
because it's propaganda it's not real
journalism
and it's not even sloppy because if it
was sloppy it would hurt democrats too
but it doesn't
it only hurts republicans and last thing
just a sidebar
this was a treasure trove a goldmine of
information on rudy's laptops and
iphones
this was communications with the
president they had stuff about the
election in there about fundraising
they had stuff in there about ukraine
about china
about hunter they're going to have this
stuff they're going to set perjury traps
and they're going to be leaking it for
years
and you shouldn't feel comfortable as a
democrat to have democrat prosecutors
just raid
lawyers offices and homes of the current
and and former presidents
that's not cool that is not cool
it is not cool all right the fastest up
there
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else